♪♪
Claire Danes:
The Essex Serpent is a
beautifully written
Claire Danes:
visceral and immediate story
about a victorian woman
Cora Seaborne.
She has recently widowed from a
very unhappy marriage.
You're free now Cora, to
explore.
Claire Danes:
Cora is kind of released into
the world and
she gets to define for herself
who she is.
Claire Danes:
She has a great passion for the
natural sciences.
And gets wind of a serpent
lurking in the Essex marshes
Claire Danes:
that really excites her
imagination.
Claire Danes:
She decides to go investigate.
I've done some research.
Into a mythical beast?
Not mythical. Real!
♪♪
In Aldwinter, this rumour that
the Essex Serpent
has returned is catching
like wildfire.
Tom Hiddleston:
Something has been bumping into
the fishing boats.
Tom Hiddleston:
A teenage girl has gone missing.
The center of that community is
the local reverend
Tom Hiddleston:
Will Ransome, and his wife
Stella,
Tom Hiddleston:
and he is doing his best to
contain the anxiety of his parishioners.
I told you.
I kept telling you we were in
danger.
(Crowd roaring)
There is no Serpent!
♪♪
For Cora it's something that
does have a scientific
explanation and Will thinks it
doesn't really exist.
Cora and Will begin an
Tom Hiddleston:
intellectual and idealogical
debate about faith and reason.
Science requires dreams just
like your theology.
Faith.
♪♪
Tom Hiddleston:
They have a deep mutual
admiration and a growing passion for each other
which is destabilizing for both
of them.
It was woman that was tempted by
the Serpent.
It's the devil!
♪♪
You let them accuse me. You said
nothing.
I'm their pastor.
So you can't be my friend and a
man of God?
I can't think clearly when I am
around you.
♪♪
Claire Danes:
I think we make the mistake of
assuming
that the Victorian era was
stayed and repressed.
Claire Danes:
I think it's subversive in how
we see our heroine who is kind of sturdy and intrepid.
Certainly look different from
the woman I met in that grand
house.
She is refusing to play the role
of the wife, the widow.
Andrea Cornwell:
It's been fascinating trying to
break stereotypes.
Claire Danes:
It has a very contemporary and
fresh feeling.
We live in times of
great change.
Exciting times!
♪♪
There's a huge element of
mystery and supernatural to the
series,
Hayley Squires:
but it also has a very strong
human drive behind it.
It sort of enlivens the past
with something very modern and
very real.
So much of the story is about
love and fear.
Claire Danes:
Its unruliness and formidable
power.
(Glass shatters)
♪♪